the parallax effect it's one of the
oldest and coolest tricks in the design
playbook it works by making different
layers of content or backgrounds move at
different speeds when the web page is
scrolled creating the optical illusion
of three-dimensional depth it's used
extensively on apple product pages like
the new iphone landing page and can be
used in subtle ways like the firewatch
game where it feels like you're
descending behind a mountain before
reaching the main content or one of the
most mind-blowing examples is the boat
which contains six chapters of non-stop
parallax looks awesome so how do i
implement it on my website over the next
few minutes you will build this homepage
of a cat parachuting from the moon down
to the ground using an awesome library
called react spring along the way you'll
learn how to quickly transform a boring
layout into something amazing at the end
of the video we will also look at some
more advanced possibilities and
drawbacks of the parallax technique if
you're new here like and subscribe and
upgrade to fireship pro to get more
tutorials like this let's first make
sure we understand how the parallax
effect works we have a background image
two images actually of the moon and a
landscape but we also have text and
images in the foreground that scroll at
different speeds on top of that you'll
notice that the text animates in with a
springy animation the cat starts at the
bottom and then very slowly scrolls up
to the top this simulates how
perspective can change the relative
speed of objects as the viewpoint moves
making the website feel much more alive
to get started create a react app with
your favorite tool i'm using beat from
there install the react spring parallax
package if you're not familiar react
spring is an awesome tool that can
easily add life to your components with
spring animations which itself is a
technique that relies on physics instead
of durations and curves for defining
animations the library provides two
components the first of which is
parallax you can think of a parallax
scene as multiple pages that gives us a
context to start animating to animate
the children we use the parallax layer
component by default you can think of
each layer as a page that will take up
the entire screen to see it in action
let's go ahead and add two different
layers you can add whatever ui you want
inside of them using the default
settings you'll notice that they're
stacked on top of each other in this
example we have four pages and by
default each layer will start on the
first page we can change that by
updating the offset to one on our second
layer that will tell it to start at the
top of the second page okay but now it
doesn't really do anything interesting
we just have two headings like a normal
website we can start making things look
cool by changing the speed of one of the
layers this will tell it to scroll at a
different speed than everything else the
difference is subtle but you'll notice
the second layer of text moves at a
different speed and as you move it will
also use a spring animation making it
appear more lifelike but to really take
advantage of parallax you'll want to
have background images the parallax
layer component can also take a style
inside of which we might define a
background image now generally speaking
your background images will move slower
than everything else and you may want to
have them span multiple pages the factor
prop allows us to do that by default
every layer will have a factor of 1
which means that its size is equal to 1
page you can make it span multiple pages
or a fraction of a page by updating the
factor value i'm going to go ahead and
add another background image and then
tweak some of our values here to give us
a scene that looks like this as we
scroll down the page we get different
layers of text animating into it and by
the way i obtain these images from
pexels.com which in my opinion is the
best place to get free stock photography
now the final piece in the scene is the
skydiving cat to make that possible i'm
using an animated gif now another cool
thing about this library is that we can
also make a parallax layer sticky which
will keep it in the same place as the
user scrolls to configure it we just use
the sticky prop and then tell it when to
start being sticky and then when to end
in this case it will start at the
beginning of the second page and end
halfway down the third page that's
pretty cool but one other thing we might
want to do is jump around to pages more
quickly we can grab the parallax element
with the use ref hook that will give us
access to a scroll to method we can put
it to use with an event handler when one
of the headings is clicked that will
scroll to a specific page automatically
and now the end user can navigate the
entire scene without having to touch the
scroll wheel with just a few lines of
code we've created a very unique
animated webpage react spring parallax
is awesome but it may feel somewhat
limited another library that you may
want to check out for more advanced use
cases is react scroll parallax which
provides more control over the elements
being animated now if you're not using
react a vanilla javascript library
that's been popular for many years is
scroll magic but one thing that needs to
be mentioned is that parallax effects in
general tend to be overused and abused
even though it looks cool it isn't
glamorous or cool
or kid stuff
it's the most addictive kind of cocaine
and it can kill you it can hurt the
usability of the site personally i get
kind of annoyed by apple landing pages
they're visually stunning but the
usability suffers as a result when
implementing the parallax effect i'd
recommend keeping it fairly subtle with
the firewatch landing page being a good
example of this you can find the source
code for this project on github and if
you like five-minute tutorials like this
let me know what you want to see next in
the comments thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one